this video is brought to you by Sun
basket what's up guys Jared here with
our third wisecrack vlog the Internet
has been ablaze revisiting the complete
show that was 2017 s fire festival since
two documentaries were released on hulu
and netflix it seems that people can't
stop thinking about it and I don't think
it's simply because we can't look away
from a train derailed fire festival is
the perfect symbol for a lot of things
happening in our culture right now for
those of you who don't know a 25 year
old entrepreneur named Billy McFarland
and Ja Rule's sold thousands of tickets
to a music festival in the Bahamas by
paying a bunch of instagrams most
popular influencers to appear in a
promotional video promising an
experience of a lifetime probably as
this festival had no chance of happening
they promised an exclusive island once
owned by Pablo Escobar they were given
the backyard of a Sandals resort they
were promised luxurious accommodations
they were given wet mattresses and
overpopulated FEMA tents and a cruel
interpretation of meatless Monday they
were promised nights of models drinking
and dancing while listening to a
legendary lineup they got a night locked
in the Bahamas Airport hungover and
starving turns out Billy's been
defrauding investors this whole time and
gets sentenced to six years behind bars
people have criticized this event from
every angle whether it's the absurdity
of Silicon Valley hustle culture Billy's
seeming sociopathy or Jerry's dubious
role in all this there's certainly no
shortage of digital ink spilled on the
fire festival but rather than thinking
about fire fest has some weird
aberration of modern culture we like to
think of it as a definitive microcosm of
the world we live in so welcome to this
luxurious curated experience from the
minds of wisecrack as we take an
exclusive journey into the bowels of
fire fest let's start off talking about
the rich and powerful since the
establishment of monarchy and nobility
in general people have flaunted their
status with objects we've dug up
prehistoric graves decked out with
ancient bling precious metals jewelry
and pottery
with the decline of nobility in places
like Europe nothing much changed your
upstart new money merchants sought to
emulate the old rich by wearing the same
clothes and owning the same fast forward
to today where young people are often at
least in part rejecting this logic it's
not that people don't want nice cars or
clothes anymore but younger generations
have put a newfound premium on
experiences and don't get me wrong this
is great there's evidence out there that
says you'll be happier spending a
thousand dollars on a vacation than say
a 4k gaming monitor many of today's
trust fund kids don't necessarily flash
their cash but instead pretend to be
broke hipsters flaunting their culture
and worldliness but among this generally
positive trend something dark has
emerged experiences themselves have
become a fake enter fire fest fire
festival is the quintessential
experience to sell to rich people
I mean people of wealth it's the party
of all parties something reserved for
the best of the best more than something
to spend thousands of dollars on fire is
an affirmation of who you are or you
could be one can emulate the decadent
lifestyle of Pablo Escobar by partying
on his private island with the world's
most famous models while this kind of
experiential snobbery has certainly
blossomed in the last decade the reason
why was described by philosopher Jean
Baudrillard in 1968 as he wrote in his
work system of objects everywhere today
in fact the ideology of competition
gives way to a philosophy of self
fulfillment in a more integrative
society individuals no longer compete
for the possession of goods they
actualized themselves and consumption
beau Gerard was in this case talking
about material goods people like Billy
McFarlane need to live in a swanky
penthouse and drive expensive cars to
give off the air that a I'm an important
guy that you should trust with millions
of dollars this kind of materialism
centric society as argued by fellow
philosopher DITA board quickly
transforms into a world where the image
of wealth overcomes the existence of
wealth Billy flexing his money only
mattered insofar as he put up the appeal
of wealth as the board said being
devolves into happy but something else
weird happens with this the logic of
elitism tends to contradict itself while
fire puts on the image of being an
exclusive party for the world's elite
Billy admits in the documentary that the
messaging is meant for some average joke
as Baudrillard writes advertising tells
us at the same time by this force like
nothing else
the bubbly happy but also by this
because everyone else is using it in a
world for the image of wealth is more
important than the wealth itself fire
fest is the perfect ticket if
experiences are the new ways in which
the rich communicate their supposed
superiority then fires let's even
ordinary people act like the super-rich
if it both is and isn't for the elite we
can also see how the experience of
something like a successful fire fest or
a burning man can be labeled artificial
or it both is and isn't real nano that's
a bit confusing so let me explain in the
novel white noise by Don DeLillo a
family goes to visit the most
photographed barn in America as they
approach the barn they're saturated with
images of the barn plastered on
billboards and postcards one character
comments nobody sees the bar once you've
seen the sides about the barn it becomes
impossible to see the bone they're not
here to catch our image we're here to
maintain one every photograph reinforces
the aura
we've agreed to be a part of a
collective perception a religious
experience in a way like all tourism
they're taking pictures of taking
pictures the elevated importance to
which people treat the barn has nothing
to do with the bar in itself but rather
the proliferation of images of the bar
when you visit the most photographed
barn in the world you're not there to
look at the barn you're there to be
there to be one of the group whose
collective reverence elevates the barn
to something more than just a bunch of
wood planks nobody gives a [ __ ] about
the barn they care about taking part
in the social aura that deems the barn
special ever been to a concert where
people record video of the performance
instead of actually watching the
performance driven to Joshua Tree just
to get a profile pic when you do these
things you've stopped having an
experience and I've started partaking in
an aura and this is the appeal of the
fire festival in nutshell it was an
events propelled entirely by a
promotional video that sold an aura and
even if the festival was a total success
the aura of the video would have
mattered more than the festival itself
you want to go to the fire festival
because you want to be part of
maintaining the impossible aura that was
sold to you you would go and capture a
single frame of something beautiful and
posted to Instagram with a hashtag that
celebrated a once-in-a-lifetime
experience to thinkers like poetry art
into lulo it never really is about the
experience it's about maintaining the
aura of the experience the experience
always disappoints the Bahamas are hot
and full of mosquitoes and hanging
around models will probably only serve
to distort your self-esteem but that one
Instagram image will obscure all those
annoyances and function as a small but
integral part in elevating the
experience to the sublime promised in
the video for Baudrillard when we
consume products were not consuming say
a bar of chocolate we're consuming its
meaning and for baudrillard the world
has been completely overcome by this
logic the symbols of things have
completely overcome the things
themselves the promo video was perfectly
generic Fantasia of what an Instagram
come to life would be and as a result
the best way to be part of fire fest is
not to have a fun time at the festival
but to Telegraph to all of your
followers how you are having fun even or
especially if it's all [ __ ] we must
consume the festival's meaning and then
regurgitate that meaning for everyone
else and there are a lot of people in
the millennial generation that are
interested in experiences that
are effectively like pretext for really
good instagrams and it's not just music
festivals and barns take the pop-up
museum in which a company rents a space
fills it with objects and deems it and
experience this phenomenon spawned an
amazing article from writer Amanda Hess
entitled the existential void of the pop
up experience whether it's the Museum of
ice-cream the Museum of pizza or the
color factory has details how the act of
learning becomes mandatory fun at the
risk of ruining other people's good
vibes of which they're going to pour
into the composition of their perfect
ball pit selfie people don't go to the
Museum of pizza to learn about pizza
they just go to take pictures with a
pizza shaped guitar donated by Andrew W
K displayed in a glass box for an extra
air of importance the real attraction is
taking part in these social media ritual
that gives something significance as has
rights the most that these spaces can
offer is the fast simile of traditional
pleasures they take nature and art and
knowledge seeking flatten them into
sight-gags
and stick them to every stray surface
and if you consider this fire themed
pop-up experience in LA which also ended
abruptly your head just might explode
perhaps nothing speaks to this more than
this moment in the Netflix documentary I
was reading about a company in Russia
that now will sell people like three
hours to do a photo shoot on a private
jet that's just parked on the tarmac
they never actually leave but they get
to take the picture like looking out the
window and pretending that they're
living this lifestyle
and they're successful for so many vague
tide of reality can be completely
untethered it's not the experience
itself but the image of that experience
that matters and that's why it's so
poetic when fire completely failed the
symbolic order comes crashing down and
were faced with the discrepancy between
the symbolic value and the actual value
between luxury villas and this buddy
passed on a few of the beds and that's
why this event has resonated so much for
us here at wisecrack aside from one
man's very relatable quest for potable
water and I got to his office fully
prepared to suck his dick that a
festival that uses something as
it is Instagram to sell itself ends up
being a complete failure functions as
the perfect representation of the
nothingness that lies underneath the
symbols and images that we perpetuate
fire is a sublime example of life hooked
on aura and the obscene shallow reality
that lurks underneath it hope you guys
enjoyed this vlog but before you go I
want to give a shout out to our sponsors
over at Sun Basket right now they're
offering wisecrack fans 60% off their
first box Sun Basket is a food delivery
service that takes the hassle out of
cooking a meal after a long day at the
office the best part about it is that
they cater to all different diets
including paleo gluten-free pescetarian
diabetes friendly vegetarianism and
veganism now what I personally love
about this is if trying a new diet is
something you've been wanting to try but
haven't had the time or the drive to
make it happen son basket makes it so
easy to make good on your plans it's
healthy it's delicious and all you have
to do is pick any of their meals choose
how many people you need to cook for and
boom a fun meal delivered right to your
door I even prepared some of their
teriyaki tempeh with the team it was
easy to make and delicious right now son
basket is giving wisecrack viewers 60%
off their first box all you got to do is
head to get son basket comm slash
wisecrack or click the link in the
description and as always thanks for
watching guys peace